let me start by saying congratulations
on the movie uh you guys did such a
great job with the script and i wish i
could talk specifics today but that will
be for another day
um
i would imagine that both of you are in
a very unique position right now that
people want to
you know they want to hear your ideas
and what you want to work on i've been
asking this of a lot of people recently
if you could get the financing to make
anything you want what would you make
and why oh man i mean the truth of it is
like sort of like making a film like
last night in soho is the thing that you
get made is like i mean in in a weird
way like sort of
you know like
after i did baby driver you know which
was my biggest hit worldwide by quite a
long way
you know
that's that's the time when you sort of
get a passion project off the ground
it's like now's the time to make last
night in touhou because i think sort of
you know in terms of like big ip
franchise films like they'll they'll
never go away weirdly
that maybe that not not necessarily that
like um i know where i'm going with this
but i i feel like the the
making original movies when you have the
opportunity should always be
the sort of the the first port of call
if if you could magic a project into
existence that's not to say that i would
never do a franchise film and not be
dumb enough to kind of put that on
record but but in a weird way like
something like this was like something
that if if if i could get something made
this was the film
yeah i mean i i something original would
be my preference or the next night in
soho i would do that
i don't know where you go after this one
i mean we have no sequel ideas right
um this is one of these you thomas and
he's been through enough yeah no more
for her
christy if i'm not mistaken you worked
as a barmaid in london earlier in your
life and i'm curious what would people
be like surprised to learn about working
in the as a bar mate in london
well i mean i actually worked as a
bartender in the bar that's in the film
and i'm i'm briefly in the background of
the film you see this arm but nothing
else because i can't act um yeah just
just this arms and extra um i think what
you'd be surprised about with that bar
in particular and and and in soho is
that you know soho is the the sort of
the showbiz district it's the
entertainment hub it's where all the
post houses are um but it's also like
full of brothels and um and
a long time ago when i was working at
that bar there used to be a dominatrix
that worked across the road and we used
to get to sit and watch her clients come
in and then she would come in and tell
us everything about her clients and we
would give her vodka and ask her to stop
telling us stories but like that kind of
thing is it's just such a
it's a world where
the you know the dark side and the light
glossy side are separated by like a
hair's breath
yeah i've walked around soho a number of
times and it is
you can just feel the history as you're
walking up and down these streets um
edgar can you sort of talk about where
where did the germ of this idea come
from and did it come from a drunken
bender in soho
um well i think actually what you said
is exactly is actually the the the
i think there's two types of people that
walk around and any city that has
history is people who walk around and
don't think about that at all and
probably people like yourself and me and
christy who who can't think of anything
else
and i think that's something that really
was like this or
the the key sort of seed of the idea was
you know you see buildings that are 400
years old in soho that have seen so much
history
and i sort of a big believer in the idea
that like um
if not actual ghosts the idea of like
psychic residues left behind
like the sort of the residue of an event
like there's a line in the movie where
somebody says that like
in london somebody's died in every room
in every building in this whole city i
believe that
and like so you know i can't help
thinking about that um in in a city like
london and
you know london's one of those places
where where the ground floors change
like all the restaurants and the clubs
on the ground floor change but as soon
as you look up to like one like story
higher and look towards the roofs you
see like the sort of the old buildings
and you're sort of much more aware of
like the the you know these these places
have been here for hundreds of years and
and the shadows of the past let loom
large so that was like one of the key
kind of like um inspirations for the
movie uh edgar you are obviously a very
talented screenwriter um and christy
obviously you are also a very talented
screenwriter and i'm curious how you
each complemented each other in the
screenwriting process for example
did you know did someone come up with an
idea that the other person would have
never thought about because of your
different perspectives on life and the
way you write
well
i think um and so two parts to that i
think sort of we um i had written the
story
like quite a long time ago and i'd sort
of been sort of sort of gearing up to
try and make it and the first thing i
did was was hired a researcher to sort
of research every single part of
the movie in in a real way so that you
know in a way that eloise is kind of
trying to sort through her perception of
the decade versus the reality and that's
also what i had to do in terms of i had
this idea for the story and it's like
well let's research it properly and when
christy came on board um it was through
actually sam mendes introduced us and
said that we would get on like a house
on fire which we did but it was when
christy mentioned that she'd worked in
soho and lived above
um sunset strip a strip club on dean
street i was like i have this idea for
this movie and i want to run it past you
so we went on a kind of like a tour of
uh soho drinking horns and i basically
like i was around the campfire i pitched
christy the entire story but one thing i
say and i'll let so christy from her
perspective is that there was that thing
in terms of like just a wanting to write
with christine b just like
our own shared history of the
neighborhood and obviously like her is
very different from mine as well that
that was all gonna inform the story one
thing i would say is that i had the
outline for the movie but one one key
thing that like when you say did they
somebody else suggest something when i
like went through the whole plot with
christy and when we first started
writing together physically when i asked
her to write the screenplay with me
is i had originally envisaged the
60 sequences as being silent and being
like sort of you know like dream
sequences where people didn't speak and
christy was you know said to me i think
you have to if you need if you're going
to fall in love with sandy like eloise
becomes obsessed with sandy you need to
like meet the character
and it was like one like simple change
which kind of then i think in a great
way just like affected the whole movie
and also for me
like then was the sort of key to sort of
some of my favorite sequences because
writing all of the 60s
dialogue was like a real sort of
challenge and a joy at the same time so
that's something that christy suggested
that i hadn't previously thought of
um i mean
like i think a really good collaboration
when you get to the end of it you're not
quite sure who came up with what because
it's like so kind of gone back and forth
and become so unmeshed so like i'm not
quite sure
what's what would be mine and what would
be yours because it's just it's you know
it's a team effort not just from the
like the script but like the entire crew
um but what i must say is writing with a
very talented writer director like edgar
wright is kind of wonderful i mean it's
exceptionally wonderful because when
you're trying to work out how these
sequences work and you know a lot of the
like
the in-camera trickery that we do or
that they do and
it's so beyond me
occasionally he would show me clips on
youtube and he'd be like like something
like this kind of movement and and like
magic tricks and stuff like that and i'd
be like i understand i did not
understand and even even when i was on
set i was still like how is this
happening who's the wizard is there some
sort of cgi going on here and it wasn't
so like stuff like that and
understanding like the vision the pace
all the music of the tone of the story i
mean that's all this very talented man
here
uh one of the things um did you guys
actually write with any thought of
actors in mind or do you not do that at
all
i mean i guess there are some like
people
like
certainly like
the character that terence stamp plays
when you're writing you're thinking i
can't think of anybody better than
terrence down to play this part
interestingly in the role of eloise
uh anya was always in mind for that part
because i had seen her
in 2015 in the witch i was on the
sundance jury that year and i you know
he gave robert eggers best director i
saw her in the witch and i was like and
at this point the so as i call it the
soho film or the soho project it existed
only as like the outline and like the
research but i was like
she needs to be in my soho film so i met
anya for coffee in la
and i ended up telling her the entire
plot over coffee and she was like oh
that sounds wild i want to be in that
movie
so i said well when as soon as i write
it i'll let you know then over the next
three years i would run into anu every
now and again and i start to feel like
the boy who cried wolf because she must
have thought i was like a crazy person
like oh yeah edgar wright with his soho
film that will never come to pass
so anyway when we then started writing
in 2018 by this point anya's been in
several other movies you know i'd seen
her kind of like sort of mature on
screen and like play parts in like split
and thoroughbreds
and then as we were writing and and sort
of as a as a nature of the sandy part
expanding
and and seeing sort of anya like sort of
like kind of like
you know kind of like uh
like
blossom like a butterfly on the red
carpet i was like and you know just one
of those people who looks like she could
fit into any era i was thinking huh
maybe like anya should play the sandy
part like she sings like that we've now
got a singing scene in the movie maybe
anya is the 60s part so when we finish
the script i sent her the draft first
draft and i said okay plot twist i'd
like you to read
sandy and not ed louise and luckily she
said i love the script and i would love
to play sandy so
we sort of wrote it with annie in mind
but for the other part
okay so one of the one of the things
that i think the film does exceptionally
well and hopefully will stay connected
is that it keeps the audience off
balance the entire time like you're
constantly wondering exactly what's
going on
how does that work in in in the script
stage in terms of
writing that sort of off-kilter
feeling or is that sort of established
also in the editing room where you're
you know what i mean can you sort of
talk about that
i guess that's
established in the script it's not
something that we're kind of finding it
in the edit i think sort of in in a way
like
you know me and paul matchless kind of
edit on set so we kind of like sort of
like you use you know sort of
constructing it as we go along but but i
i think that was always the idea with
the movie in terms of like
you know you you're
you're
what to me an interesting thing about it
and this kind of informs the entire
movie this doesn't give too much away
but like i always like the idea of the
dream sequences in the movie
being like having like ellipses between
them so you're getting like a story but
you're not getting the whole story
you're getting little glimmers of this
story so there's a moment in the sort of
like from one dream to the next it's not
really clear whether uh with matt smith
and annie taylor joy's story at one
point he's like is this the next night
or is this like nine months later it's
not entirely clear and also because
thomas in uh eloise uh played by thomas
mckenzie she doesn't have that
information either she's only like
getting kind of like
literally these little kind of like
shards of somebody else's life and then
so she has to sort of piece it together
from this kind of like
um experience that she's had i mean
there's a scene in the movie where she
she goes to the police i don't think
this is too much of a spoiler but when
she starts to say out loud
what her perception of the plot is it
obviously sounds completely absurd as it
would be if you went to see a police
officer saying okay
so this is happening and but but that's
her reality and so that was a fun thing
for us to write because you're seeing
the film through the eyes of somebody
who has a power that other people can't
comprehend
and obviously people like think that you
know that she's like so maybe like
losing her marbles but we as an audience
know that she isn't
yeah i i actually love that scene
because it's what someone might actually
do in that situation it's not playing
you know it's treating the anyway that's
a that's a thing but uh i am curious
about the editing process you know i
love talking about it because it's the
final rewrite and where it all comes
together how did the film
change in the editing room in maybe ways
you weren't expecting and how much did
you end up losing with like deleted
scenes and other things like that
i think there's a couple of things there
were a couple of scenes that we cut out
like there was a couple of scenes that
we cut out even before we showed it to
an audience and after we did one test
screening there was like a big scene
which we eliminated
and and usually with those things it's
like if people talk about oh is there
anything you wanted to keep in it's like
no usually when you take a scene out
it's like an amputation it's like sort
of like you know this foot is diseased
and as soon as you cut it off um
it's like you immediately feel better
and it's like that scene is never going
back in it's just like sort of it's
better it's better without it what we
did have with this is that when we did
some additional photography
post panda not post pandemic mid
pandemic we were supposed to do some
additional photography the week of the
shutdown and so we basically
had to kind of go home for like seven
months and we were one of the first
films to come back and shoot in the uk
so there was there was a week in late
july where the only films shooting in
the uk were jurassic world and last
night in soho
both shooting at pinewood and also very
surreal experience because a very
emotional experience because
everybody was so happy to be back at
work people were sort of nervous about
how is this how is filming going to work
in a covert area era like
and so we were having to kind of
navigate that but also you really felt
that everybody was so happy to be
working
and actually in a way like we we knew
what we wanted to do but like six months
off kind of informed some things where
you can really kind of nail down what it
is you want to do so in some cases it
was about kind of like adding bits of
storytelling to make things kind of like
work in a slightly different way
and there was one like deleted scene
which included like a key line but i
hated the scene and i wanted to get rid
of it so then it was like oh we're going
to write a new scene to replace this one
and it's going to include the line that
we need from the scene that's been gone
so just that stuff where
listen this is
you know listen a lot of people kind of
treat reshooting as somehow a negative
thing if it's like studio mandated and
something is like testing badly
or you know and and the filmmaker is
doing it against his wishes but pretty
much in everything i've done
when i've had the opportunity to do
additional photography it's usually to
refine storytelling not in a dissimilar
way to where they make an animated movie
you know how the pixar films are made
you know or how like phil and chris make
animated movies is that you're
constantly like rewriting rewriting
rewriting so we had to one attempt to do
that is that how can we and
there's an opportunity here to make some
bits a bit more succinct or a bit more
emotional and to some sometimes go in
and redo just little parts of scenes you
know and
i actually think the sort of the stuff
that we did here like was so kind of
seamless that even when the studio
watched it back they were like
was that seen in there before like um
they were
like so impressed by the continuity of
what we'd shot of like putting little
things in that like weren't previously
there and it's amazing
you know i always find that it's amazing
what how you can
change things so it becomes like the
butterfly effect is usually like if you
do a test screening and something's not
working
people say oh it doesn't work cut it out
and you say now
it's like me and george miller were
talking about it it's like referred pain
it's like you know the pain might be in
this shoulder but actually the
acupuncture needle wants to go in this
shoulder so it's that thing where so
that's where editing and actually that
process of showing to an audience is an
interesting thing where it's like if you
change this it actually affects
something like 45 minutes later
it's interesting you bring up the
additional photography because i think
that additional photography has a bad
stigma with some people but it's all
about the context of the additional
photography as you said whether it be
studio demanded or filmmakers like three
days could make this movie so much
better absolutely i think it's a thing
like sort of like when it's when it's
talked about in a negative way people
call it reshooting but filmmakers who
would kill for an extra couple of days
call it additional photography
what are you really excited for fans to
see with this movie that perhaps they're
not getting or they haven't seen before
or haven't seen in a long time
well i think you know cinema in itself
is transportative you know cinema on the
big screen is transportative like and
this movie you know you get to go on a
journey with eloise's character like the
main takeaway i've had from people
who've watched the movie have said wow i
really feel like i i went on a went on a
journey with their character and had a
real experience and so
i guess because like a lot of my other
movies like
the league character is in every single
scene so you've really it feels
hopefully very experiential which you
know to me is like
the best of cinema is like that that you
go on a journey with a character
yeah absolutely i mean get off your
couch go and get sucked into someone
else's life for a change like you know
i've spent so much time at home during
the pandemic and just being back in
cinemas
and getting to you know be transported
away that's that's what i hope people
get and they're thrilled
and scared
yeah i definitely listen i know that
it's not for everyone going back to the
cinema right now with the pandemic but i
will say that the use of color and the
editing and the filmmaking on display in
this film is something that like it just
screams cinema you know
oh thank you i mean i think the thing is
as well i know sometimes it's
controversial like where people say like
if you're saying you have to see this on
the big screen i think for me the key is
we want to give people the opportunity
to see on the big screen that's the
important distinction there